foreign
I want to turn to this notion of
um you know the simulation hypothesis
which you're intimately connected with
and uh as I said you know not asking you
to Define it would be like not asking
Abba to sing dancing queen uh so I
wonder if you could in your 30 second
manner that I've heard you do it in the
past if you would please indulge me with
some forbearance and and repeat what
what you mean by that
um well 30 seconds will be challenging
but yeah simulation the simulation
argument tries to show that at least one
of three possibilities actually obtained
um although it doesn't tell us which one
so what are those three well number one
possibility is
amongst all the civilizations at our
current stage of technological
development
almost none attained technological
maturity so they all go extinct before
they develop
the full range of technologies that we
know are physically possible in
second possibility is there is this
strong convergence among all
civilizations that do become
technologically mature they all just
lose interest in using those immense
technological powers for the purpose of
creating large numbers of
ancestor simulations detailed
simulations with conscious digital
beings in them
um so those are two right and then the
third possibility
is we are living in a computer
simulation
the simulation argument uh kind of
demonstrates that at least one is true
by assuming that the first two are false
and then seeing that if those first two
possibilities did not obtain we would
have strong reason for believing in the
third
right so that then suggests you can't
project all three and so at least one of
them has to hold
and you know it's safe to say that that
you know there's been you know
tremendous interest and attention given
to it and when I talked to David
Chalmers about on his most recent book
on reality plus uh I believe he called
it a wonderful book I'll link to it in
the links above uh that you know he
basically
suggests the likelihood is extremely
high in other words it's not just that
there are these three probability
possibilities they all have equal weight
there there's actually in his mind a
great deal of evidence for it and I
started to ask him uh and I don't know
if I fully understood his answer but in
some sense we in astronomy have you know
the Drake equation for for talking about
similar things uh the possibility there
could be aliens we could have been
aliens we'll get to aliens later by the
way uh but um you know we we could have
been seated here on Earth by aliens so I
started talking about this concept of
the Drake equation in some way of
codifying the probability and I always
say the Drake equation makes me a little
bit angry because uh it's really just a
product of six different numbers uh and
the really interesting things as you
know as a scientist is not the numbers
themselves the central value but the
error bars that you assign on it right
yeah anyway it's probably like the most
overhyped equation in in all of science
more than E equals m c squared well I
mean E equals 70 squared is like a d
profound revolutionary Insight that took
immense genius to arrive at right I mean
the bigger question as you said is just
like yeah multiplying a bunch of numbers
so I came over the Chalmers you know
equation the analog thing but I wonder
if you could walk through like the
individual you know kind of
probabilities of these different situ
these different outcomes that one of
which should obtain
um is it you know kind of proper to
think about it in terms of address a
proper Drake Equation where you're
assigning likelihood based on some
Bayesian prior confidence intervals
um on all these things and then we can
assess the individual challenges to each
one of the input priors as well as our
Precision on how well we understand them
so can you could you assign some some
previous knowledge to these um these
three different uh conjectures and then
ask which one is if not uh you know
definitively more probable is at least
most most likely to be true
well I guess the thing with the
simulation argument is that any of the
three possibilities is would be striking
if true
um so if if the first one were the true
one then it means we are basically
doomed right we will contrary to what we
might hope and expect not actually
develop these Technologies
that we're not to be physically possible
and and that's the more striking if we
think that we are actually pretty close
to being able to do this so if if you
are amongst the people who for example
think Super intelligence uh might well
be developed in this Century then if the
first
hypothesis were true right the first uh
disjunct that would mean
not only that we would have to
go extinct soon in this Century before
we reach super intelligence
or otherwise sort of stop all
technological progress which already
would be pretty surprising and alarming
but also that the same would hold true
for basically all other technological
civilizations
uh throughout the cosmos
so
um
so it's not as if that would be a shark
that would be like a major big uh
Revelation about the world that would be
very surprising the second possibility
also would be kind of surprising if you
think that there is this immense
convergence where everybody would just
refrain
from using the powerful computers that
they could buy
allocating just a tiny percentage of a
small number of their vast numbers of
computers for just
you know a few minutes produce enormous
quantities of these answers to
simulations and I wouldn't even do that
not just without our uh
descendants not do that but again it
would have to be a pretty Universal
pattern throughout the universe so that
that also would be striking what could
cause such a convergence in behavior and
and then the simulation hypothesis is of
course striking
um and so I think that's what gives
simulation arguments its own even before
you roll in and if other surmises you
might have about how the probability
should be apportioned as between these
three alternatives